today on the Matt Walsh show as the
corona virus pandemic grows and the
government response to it becomes even
more severe and extreme there's another
crisis happening that's fueling some of
the panic and division that people are
feeling that is a crisis of trust I
think people don't know which sources of
information to trust which is a big
problem at a time like this and
meanwhile pundits and commentators and
media personalities like myself feel
perfectly entitled to issue
proclamations and opinions and analysis
even though none of us have any idea
actually what's going on and very few of
us have any expertise on the subject of
viral pandemics we don't understand the
science or the medicine behind it yet
we're still talking about it and telling
you what you should think and how you
should feel about it it's a mess and so
today we're gonna try to sort through it
on our way to attempting to answer the
question of who should we trust about
this issue where should we be going for
information what what should our sources
of information be it's a very important
question that we will try to answer
today also five headlines including the
grumpy old men debate last night that
happened and a former Democratic
gubernatorial candidate was caught in
Florida in a hotel room with drugs and a
male escort and lots of people think
this is the end of his political career
but he has a Democrat so is it possible
that this would help his political
chances going forward we'll discuss that
and a couple of emails from listeners
including one from Grant who is very
upset about some of the things I said on
my show on Friday wants to tell me why
I'm wrong about them and we'll get to
that as well all of that coming up but
first here's possibly the best news
you'll hear all day and there's a lot of
bad news so it's not a very high hurdle
to get over but still right now using
promo code Walsh you'll get 10% off any
daily Wired membership plan and and let
me tell you this if you're not a member
you're missing all the best stuff you're
missing the full daily wire experience
as I call it as I just started calling
it right now
members get our articles ad free you get
access to all of our live broadcasts you
get to show library all of that you get
the full three hours of Ben Shapiro show
select bonus content access to the
mailbag and much more plus our new all
access to your gets you into exclusive
live
online Q&A discussions with me and ben
shapiro and andrew Clavin Michael
Knowles plus daily wire writers and also
special guests that come along and do
these q and A's as well it's a lot of
fun don't forget you'll also get the
greatest of all beverage vessels and
that which your kitchen cupboard would
not be complete without that is the
leftist tiers tumbler all of that plus
10% off when using promo code Walsh so
get over to daily wire comm daily wire
comm and become a member today
ok coronavirus so this is tough trying
to figure out exactly what I is it's a
kind of a tough job to do right now and
I mean not nearly as tough as as the job
done by almost anybody else on earth
right now I work from home I do this
show I write the only time my job takes
me out of the house really as if I'm
doing a speech but those have all been
canceled as you might expect through
April and possibly beyond so I have it
really easy and I'm very fortunate we
also homeschool our kids so it's easy
for us to lock down and stay in the
house and do the sort of self quarantine
deal so don't let me get all
melodramatic and weepy about the plight
of a podcaster during a pandemic
podcasting into pandemic maybe I'll
write maybe that'll be a book I write
one day but in my own little sheltered
world within that rather shallow context
there is the difficulty of the
coronavirus being obviously on
everybody's mind the thing that
everybody is talking about the thing
everyone's thinking about and something
that whether we like it or not and none
of us do has begun to take over our
lives both the thing itself the disease
and also even more so at this point the
reaction to it the governmental response
and things being shut down and all that
so I'm not going to ignore it I have no
problem ignoring big news stories and
talking about other things usually but
with this one at least for now at this
point I feel compelled to discuss it and
yet
like almost any other pundit or
commentator I'm basically clueless about
all of this I don't know anything about
viruses except for the very basic
information that everybody knows but if
you ask me you know if you even ask me
what is a virus you know I'm always
asking people what's a woman when they
talk about women I'm always throwing the
left that curveball
well when I'm talking about pandemics
and and and giving my opinions you could
throw me a curveball and say what's a
virus
what is the virus exactly can you
explain it I could give you maybe three
sentences may be talking about viruses
and of course it's a bit of a trick
question because scientists don't even
know exactly what a virus is is it alive
is it a living organism or not there's
there some debate about that but that
only goes to show how complex this
subject is it's very complex people
spend their whole life studying it and
working with it and they still don't
haven't figured out so somebody like me
who's never studied it never worked in
the field never really thought about it
what the hell could I possibly have to
offer on the subject as for pandemics
again I'm not an expert most pundits and
show hosts and commentators are not
experts how do you mean just not experts
but we've never really even thought
about it maybe we've read some books
about it maybe but what are we
historians of pandemics we could sit
here and compare while this pandemic
compares to the Spanish flu in the
following ways yeah we never really we
never thought about it until now none of
us thought that this would be the issue
at the start of 2020 this would be the
thing we were talking about we all we
thought it would be you know one of
trumps tweets or something would be the
news of the day
so what real insight can we offer on
this what what are our opinions what are
they based on exactly I've already
admitted I was wrong about this issue in
the early going I thought it would be no
big deal for the rest of the world when
this first started in China you started
hearing about it I thought it would
remain a far away thing I thought the
threat of a global pandemic was media
hype and I
said so that's what I thought and I was
very confident in that when we first
started hearing about the corona virus
in the news I was not worried about it
at all I didn't for a second believed
that it would lead to this I I didn't
see this coming at all and I was wrong
lots of other pundits and and and
commentators and hosts and cable news
personalities
we're also wrong I'm not trying to
deflect by saying they were wrong too
but they were a lot of people were very
wrong about this see the thing is though
most of them won't admit it and my gonna
say any names but they're just content
continuing along issue issuing their
prognostications delivering their
opinions with feigned Authority even
though they've been completely wrong
every step of the way everything they've
said has been wrong but they keep
adjusting keep pivoting it goes from you
know oh this is nothing but hype it's
nothing at all don't worry okay well it
is something but it's it's it's not any
worse than the flu okay well it is worse
than the flu but the but the panic is
the real problem the panic is the real
threat on and on no acknowledgement no
accountability not taking a second to
say hey you know what I've been wrong on
this so take a grain of salt with
everything I'm about to say but here's
my opinion just continuing to spew these
half-baked theories continuing to
provide analysis that's based on a near
total lack of underlying knowledge on
the subject whatever you think about
what's happening whether you think it's
overblown or not whatever you think
there's no denying that we are in the
middle of something very serious
something that is not not something that
is certainly not unprecedented in the
life of mankind collectively but it is
unprecedented in the experience of
modern Americans mostly because we have
lived a sheltered comfortable life and
we have collectively experienced very
little hardship with a few exceptions of
course notable exceptions 9/11 being one
of them and and I and you know when I
say unprecedented I refer both to the
disease and the reaction to it you know
the whole thing
this is not just an issue to be argued
about this is not something that lends
itself to talking points
it's much bigger than that we're dealing
with something much bigger the problem
is that we have so many streams of
information so many people screaming at
us so many sources of fact and opinion
and opinion masquerading as fact that
it's difficult to know who to believe
who to trust who to turn to and you're
tempted to turn it all off and say I'm
gonna tune it all out I don't want to
know I don't wanna hear any of this
stuff which maybe ultimately is not a
bad idea
but if you're like me you don't want to
do that because you want to know what's
happening you want to be prepared you
have a family you feel like you have a
responsibility to know to be prepared
but that brings you back to the question
of who do you listen to now we in the
media many of us are really arrogant
profoundly arrogant
again myself included I'm not gonna keep
saying myself included but just insert
that into everything I say we think
we're experts on everything we've taken
the fact that people listen to us about
everything as evidence that people
should listen to us about everything so
without any real thought to the
consequences without much reflection
really we start spouting off as if with
expertise about the virus about the
severity of the threat about the
government response the reasonableness
or unreasonableness of it government
started shutting down businesses in mass
yesterday New York California schools
shutting down across the country well
that happened last week but yesterday we
heard about New York and California Los
Angeles shutting down restaurants bars
and and this happened and the
commentators and pundits and media
people they all chimed in immediately
quite confident that this was either the
wrong move or the right move
they had it figured out immediately they
heard about it two seconds later I know
if this is right or wrong meanwhile this
is an incredibly morally complex issue
we're weighing the risk of economic
collapse which is a very real
when you start shutting down businesses
across entire cities and states for
weeks at a time if not longer
so weighing that against the need to
save lives which is a very real need and
the threat to human life is also very
real so if these drastic measures have a
good chance of saving a hundred thousand
lives or more and there are experts who
say that that's the case then is it
worth it I'm even if it leaves the
economy in shambles you saved all those
lives aren't human isn't human life more
important and in the economy then again
economic collapse could could threaten
human life people aren't gonna be able
to support themselves but what if what
if it only saves 10,000 lives
potentially thousand I mean how do you
balance these things what's the right
call that's a very difficult question I
don't have the answer for it I don't
know I really don't lots of people in
the media they think they do know they
they've got it figured out like I said
right away they thought about it for two
seconds boom they know and they'll tell
you all about it right now think about
that for a second think about this
something big happens New York City
shuts down schools restaurants bars in
response to a viral disease threat and
within seconds the pundit class the
media members know exactly if it was
wrong or right and they issue that
opinion with total confidence a decision
that a group of people in high levels of
state government agonized over
presumably debated a decision that
presumably was informed by intelligence
on the spread and nature of the of the
disease probably some of which we are
not privy to a decision that experts in
the field were were involved in that
decision within 12 seconds of being
announced was immediately categorized as
simply right or simply wrong the people
who made it agonized over it but the
people at the peanut gallery had it all
figured out right away well good for
them they're they're geniuses I'm not
saying it was the right decision by the
I don't know I also don't know exactly
what went into it I'm sort of assuming
that they're that all of those things
went into these decisions it's possible
that that isn't the guy I don't know I
just don't know I don't think you know I
don't think most of the people talking
to microphones and talking in cameras
today I don't think most of them know I
don't know if we'll ever know the thing
is if these measures do prevent a
catastrophe on a scale of millions
infected and many thousands dying m''d
seem that well then it was worth it
right but how will we know what could
have been we won't know lots of people
especially the media will pretend that
they know what could have been or what
can be or what will be but but but they
don't they won't they can't they never
will and so if if if the worst is
avoided and it doesn't become what a lot
of people worry it will become the
disease that is you're gonna have folks
in the media saying see I was right all
along
Yesi I told you yet how the hell do they
know it what if these measures weren't
taken what would happen they don't know
it's pretending they do they're playing
a game here's my point in a time like
this you know it's difficult to know who
to trust it's also really important to
figure that out though because the
information is important and you need to
know where to get it what I'm what I'm
saying to you what I'm telling you is is
don't listen to me don't listen to any
media personality any cable news host or
talk-show host any internet celebrity
any opinion giver on Twitter or Facebook
or anywhere else and not just media
people either
I mean I'm putting it on the media but
these days were all pundits to some we
all have an audience might be a small
one but we're all on social media giving
our opinions it's not just people who
are paid to do it and if you browsed
through Twitter or Facebook or wherever
whatever social media site you're on
you're gonna see a lot of very ignorant
opinions issued with confidence by
people who have no idea what they're
talking about have haven't the slightest
clue people who have never
about this ever in their life they've
never thought about what's the right
response to a pandemic you know how do
these things spread issues like
exponential growth and and and all these
things they've never thought about it
ever in their life not once and now it
happens and though I tried know exactly
what's going on here I'll tell you and
so it's not just from the media it's
everybody just talking at each other and
then we all end up in this haze of
contradictory conflicting opinions and
we feel like we have to choose a side
and we're looking around thinking what I
got I got to be on someone's side as am
i on the side of this isn't a big deal
or I'm on my own though this is a big
deal side or my it's it's it mean while
we're dealing with something that I mean
this is one of mankind's oldest enemies
a virus if something like this isn't
enough to make us kind of put all this
BS to the side and see how petty and
ridiculous it is and just try to be
reasonable adults about it I mean if
this can't do it then what can so I
think when you see an opinion or hear
one from a media member like myself or
really any any Joe Schmo on on Twitter
or Facebook you should you should pray
in your head you should preface whatever
they just said with an individual with
no related expertise and no base of
knowledge on the subject and who
couldn't even tell you exactly what a
virus is has the following opinion I'm
not saying that we have to have a PhD or
a degree in a related field to have an
opinion about anything in fact many
times I have railed against that
mentality the idea that you know in
order to have an opinion on any subject
you need to be able to present your
resume to prove that you have a right to
an opinion on it I don't think that but
when it comes to analyzing a specific
medical and scientific issue that has
lots of complexities and everything else
wrapped into it like the spread of a
virus the threat level it poses its
growth rate etc when it comes to
predicting what will happen next what
could happen
with this specific thing the virus when
it comes to that I think you really do
need to have some kind of base of
knowledge some expertise or else why
should anyone listen to you
why didn't anyone care what you have to
say the trouble is that the media is a
one-way forum right so we we talk and
you listen if you could respond in
real-time and ask follow-up questions
when you see a talking head on cable
news we just turn on cable news
sometimes sometimes and see that the
talking heads the analysts that are
brought in to discuss the the
coronavirus they bring in some real
experts but they also bring in the same
kinds of people they would bring in to
analyze a trump tweet just just their
their their their roster of Talking
Heads they bring in to talk these people
have no idea what they're talking about
why are they up why do you have this why
do you have this political operative
giving opinions on a virus now if you
could respond in real-time
you might ask the pundit who's giving
his opinion you might say if the pundit
is saying oh this virus isn't as bad as
everyone thinks or this virus will wipe
out mankind or whatever it is you could
say oh really why do you think that
what's your source but what's your
reason for thinking this and if you
could ask that you would quickly
discover that they have no very
compelling reason to think it or else
they're echoing and probably mangling
what they heard from a scientist or a
doctor and if that's the case your next
follow up should be okay if you got this
from a scientist or a doctor somebody
who knows what they're talking about
why don't you just point us in their
direction rather than giving us your
mangled tortured politically flavored
version of what they said why don't you
just shut up and and point us to
wherever you got this from so we can
read that instead and that brings me to
my my conclusion I for the
remainder of this event for lack of a
better word I'm not going to give you my
opinions on the nature of the virus
itself the threat it poses what will
happen with it next or anything like
that because I don't know I really don't
I'm as clueless as you I just don't know
I I know in my mind I could I hear all
the stuff about how bad it could get
thousands dead could be could go that
way
there's also another part of me that
says sad you know maybe this is all
maybe maybe three weeks from now we'll
be looking back on this as ancient
history and saying you know well we
really lost our minds over that didn't
we I don't know so instead what I will
endeavor to do is point you in the
direction of sources that are more
worthy of trust than me because they're
backed by knowledge and expertise and
experience which I lack doesn't mean you
should trust any source implicitly
but you you do have to at least
partially trust someone some source or
else there's no point in pursuing
information there's no point of being
online there's no point of turning on
the news there's no point of listening
to this show or any other I mean the
fact if you're doing that at all it must
mean that you think you can trust at
least partially someone so you know
doctor foul chief from the NIH it's been
a great source of information it seems
like the CDC World Health Organization
other health organizations have plenty
of information ER doctors who have
worked with this disease have seen it up
close and personal you know I'm not
talking about somebody's pediatrician
who hasn't seen it yet and hasn't dealt
with it but there are plenty of ER
doctors people who have been in this
weather in Italy or in California or
elsewhere they're great sources of
information might take a little bit of
digging to find what they have to say
but they've written letters and emails
that have been published and they've
articles and op-eds and everything and
you can go and find that I've shared a
few of them on this show biologists
epidemiologist doctors with specialties
and related fields I mean this is where
I'm going to get my information and if I
if I pass it along to you on this
I'm just going to quote them verbatim
I'm not gonna give you my dumb analysis
of what they said I'm not gonna tell you
well this epidemiologist says this and
here's what I think about that who gives
a damn what I think about it but you can
pursue these avenues information
yourself of course just like just like I
can and and I very much urgency to tune
out as much as possible the analysis and
opinions and prophecies of people who
don't understand this issue have no
experience with it and who spend most of
their time thinking about and talking
about political and cultural issues
that's their that's their lane that's
our lane this doesn't mean that I'm
gonna stop talking about issues related
to the pandemic
is this something happening in the world
right now it's on everyone's mind it
matters of course I'm going to talk
about it but I'll try as best I can to
steer clear of offering opinions or
analysis of the disease itself and its
trajectory and and and and that sort of
thing an opinion like this is overblown
is an opinion that can only have value
or meaning if it's informed by a deep
understanding of viral pandemics and the
science behind them and exponential
growth rates and all of that if you lack
that knowledge you're this is overblown
opinion is itself overblown ignorance
and opinions on the other side are the
same so I'm gonna try try emphasis on
try to avoid doing that and instead talk
about issues surrounding it issues that
I may have something to offer on things
like the cultural implications and you
know those sorts of things trying to
stay in my lane while still providing
content that's relevant to your
experience as we all go through this
together
that's my goal I'm just putting it out
there right now and I I really think
that this is something we all need to
consider because you want to talk about
panic and hysteria it's only gonna get
worse if we keep listening to every
dumbass sharing his ignorant
ill-informed or rather
totally uninformed opinion about a
subject he doesn't understand alright
now we'll move on let's go to emails or
no actually I'm I'm all screwed up here
let's go to see I don't even understand
my own show I can't even do my own show
so what could I tell you about a
pandemic five headlines is what we're
gonna do instead number one there was a
democratic debate last night I don't
have much to say about that either but
it was it was mostly two old men yelling
at each other they held it in studio no
audience so it was just because of the
they were trying to practice social
distancing I will say I like that format
having two people talk to each other and
and without the without the
brain-damaged hyenas in the audience
making all the noise and without the
moderator cutting in every 12 seconds
but just having them in a room no
audience just talking and arguing and
debating actually debating that was the
crazy thing about the debate last night
there was actually a little bit of real
debating which we very rarely see in a
debate so I like that as far as the
substance of it it was what you would
expect I guess the the pundits are
saying that Biden won because he escaped
without injury he escaped without injury
because he only made about five
embarrassing mistakes rather than his
normal twenty seven and so because of
that it's essentially a huge victory for
him one of the mistakes was when he and
Bernie did this also they both kept
forgetting which disease is in the news
so they went through SARS swine flu
Ebola couldn't remember I mean if you've
been living in a cave for the past few
weeks and you turned on this debate you
would be you would be really freaking
out right now because you would think
that there's a SARS swine flu corona
virus and Ebola epidemic happening all
at the same time I was kind of expecting
by the end of it they would be promising
to make sure that we finally come up
with a vaccine to defeat this polio that
this polio epidemic once and for all I
thought this is that's where this was
going but didn't quite get there Bernie
was Bernie he had a few uh few great
lines such as when he said I've got
Ebola in my head was it a direct quote
from Bernie Sanders I've got Ebola in my
head and another point he starts
bragging about all the soap he uses says
I use lots of soap
both are real quotes that he uttered but
I think his best was this have you been
on the floor of the Senate you were in
the center for a few years yeah time and
time again talking about the necessity
with pride about cutting Social Security
cutting Medicare cutting veterans
programs no you never said that no all
right America
go to the website right now go to the
YouTube right now this guy yeah I'm
telling you I can I can tell why the
youths love him he very in touch with
the youth of today he just understands
later on the debate he said that he he
stays in touch with America's youth by
listening to his Christina Aguilera CD
on his Walkman while he's rollerblading
super relevant stuff and that's it I
have nothing else to say about the
debate I hope you enjoyed hope you
enjoyed that analysis number two
interesting story here about a guy who
were in the month went to stores all
over Tennessee and bought up all the
hand sanitizer because he saw what was
coming
I bought up nearly 18,000 bottles of
hand sanitizer and then he planned to
resell it on Amazon which he did Matt
Colvin is his name he did manage to sell
a few hundred bottles at prices between
$8 and $70 for the hand sanitizer but
Amazon quickly shut him down saying that
price gouging especially during a
pandemic violates their Terms of Service
okay when this all came to the attention
of the media he was profiled in New York
Times and he was completely originally
anyway he's changed his tune but he was
originally unrepentant about price
gouging during a pandemic he never
anticipated the struggle other families
would go through because of a shortage
when you say you're sorry sorry for
purchase sorry for buying all of this
no I don't think that I would I just
like how he's he's asked if he's sorry
and then he pauses for a while and you
think he's gonna get emotional and start
apologizing spill his guts out but
instead he says nope not sorry not sorry
well after quite a bit of a let's say
social pressure including death threats
he did apologize and he decided to
donate most of his hand sanitizer and in
the state attorneys general attorney
general office attorney attorney
general's office came in from from
Tennessee that came in and they started
confiscating the rest of it so I think
he donated about 60% of it and then the
the remaining 40% the state government
came in and just took it
saying that it's against the law to
price-gouging in a price gouged during a
state of emergency but the thing is he
did this before there was a state of
emergency declared so there's a question
here about I think a rather fascinating
debate about what can the state do they
have the authority to just come in yeah
the guy's a jerk no question about it
nobody nobody would argue that but and
that's putting it mildly but does that
mean the state can just come in and take
what you bought I don't know number
three Stephen King sent out a tweet over
the weekend focusing on the important
stuff as always he said note that trumps
coronavirus team is all male all old and
all white and is what is it with old old
white male liberals always complaining
about old white males now they better
get used to old white males because
that's who they're nominee is in case
they forgot me I either way whichever
one of them it is and it's gonna be
Biden but either way it's an old white
male and I'll never quite get over the
irony that the people who complain
incessantly about old white males had a
chance to nominate a young white male
black woman a black man an old Native
American woman I think they had any of
those choices and they decided let's go
with the old white male in fact let's we
got we got two really old white males
here here
let's narrow it down to one of those two
let's make those our only options but
don't worry because the old white males
they both said yesterday during the
debate that they would make a female
their vice-president so these these guys
who worked doggedly
to kick all the females out of the race
ensuring that none of them would be
president now they're gonna make a
female they're number two they feel very
strongly that a female right now
shouldn't be president because they
should but a female should definitely
get second place
hashtag feminist heroes number for
Andrew Gilliam former candidate for
governor in Florida also former mayor of
Tallahassee considered the rising
Democratic star was caught in a hotel
room a few days ago with drugs and an
overdosed male escort lying naked on his
bed Gilliam is married with three kids
by the way so you know it's it's being
said that this is gonna destroy his
political career but I I don't see that
it does if anything I think it might
help him and I'm I'm not I'm not
actually kidding I think we're at the
point now with Democrats where I don't
know if he's ever gonna win governor but
at least in terms of his future as an
influencer on the Democratic side I
think this probably helps him
number five here's some great news at
least for me a new study finds that
people who are stubborn and
argumentative are less likely to get
Alzheimer's does that sound like anyone
you know stubborn argumentative
I mean if stubbornness and being
argumentative health then I'm I'm
basically immortal and it gets better
though because researchers are also
saying that being stubborn argumentative
and combining that with an aversion to
conformity is the best combo so stubborn
argumentative contrarian don't get along
well with others
check check check check now they just
need to tell me that having a bad temper
is the is the is the final trait you
need and that's gonna really tell me
that I'm impervious to illness I will
never die all right let's go to your
daily cancellation and today we'll be
we'll be canceling and this is for the
sake of humor
really for our own for everybody this is
for everyone I figure out this is a
treat I'll give to everybody at a time
when I think we all really need it we
will be canceling all mathematical
statistics especially those involving
the number 500 million so you remember
last week the famous incident involving
the 500 million statistic on MSNBC with
Brian Williams and the woman who we
later discovered was a victim of racism
because people made fun of her that she
can't do math we won't get into that
again well there was another one another
incident like that involving a different
leftist we're really on the verge of an
epidemic here and and the only way to
stop it is to act quickly and take
precautions which is why I'm canceling
statistics involving the number 500
million in fact I think I'm gonna cancel
statistic and I'm gonna cancel
mathematics in general I think it's the
only safe way so here is Brianna joy
gray works for the Sanders campaign and
she tweeted the other day she says it's
great that everybody is coming together
around this crisis but people are in
crisis every day 500 million Americans
go bankrupt from medical debt every year
68 million are uh nor underinsured we've
been in a state of emergency we need a
president who acts like it five hundred
million Americans go bankrupt every year
five hundred million American okay that
would mean either that there's five
hundred million people in America and
every single one of them goes bankrupt
every year annually or there are
billions of Americans possibly trillions
and five hundred million of them go
bankrupt every year in either case
there's a bit of a problem with accuracy
or accuracy here there are in fact three
hundred twenty seven million Americans
five hundred thousand of them go
bankrupt every year so she was only off
by about what four hundred ninety nine
point five million it's a slight slight
slight error that's all but I don't
blame here blame her really because
clearly there is a problem and the
problem is with math itself math we must
remember according to Scripture was
invented by the devil it took us many
years to free ourselves from the chains
of mathematics but we did with the
invention of calculators and then the
final blow to math camp
when we invented cell phones so that we
could carry calculators around in our
pockets all the time without looking
like dorks it was just kind of a way of
really the cell phone originally I don't
know if you're familiar with the history
but originally it was invented just as a
way as a cover basically a cover story
for an alibi for the calculator that we
all carry around in our pockets so that
any and now anytime there's a math
question we come across any sort of math
difficulty just pull out your phone and
that's it that's all you need to do use
your calculator and if it's a more
complicated question like you know if
somebody were to ask me to find the
hypotenuse of a prime number of a
trigonometry then I could just google it
and if the calculator and Google don't
work then I can cry and tell you to stop
harassing me that's the last resort
either way math is not needed and is
therefore cancelled now let's go to
emails remember you can become a daily
wire member and you get access to the
mailbag and I would encourage everyone
to do that we're gonna go right to a
couple of interesting emails I'll save a
few of them for later in the week but
we'll go right to grant with ry I'm
wrong segment grant says hi Matt I have
to tell you I was really angry about
what you said about the president on
your show I know that you're going for
those clicks by jumping on the Blaine
Trump bandwagon but I really thought
better of you
I didn't start listening to your show to
hear someone go along with the media
narrative and say the popular things
like any other grifter extremely
disappointed okay grant so I guess it's
time for the bimonthly tradition where I
explain how grifting and click hunting
works in the age of Trump because a lot
of people don't seem to understand and
since where it's been the theme of the
show I'm talking about the media and how
useless we all are well maybe I'll that
this is a good way to cap it off so
here's another explanation of how things
worked in media I yeah I did I did
criticize Trump on my show on Friday it
criticized his response to the crisis at
least his response up until Friday when
I did the show because I thought it was
worthy of criticism he's been better
since then but up until that point it
was bad in my opinion so I gave my
opinion I gave my reasons
agree or disagree with them but I'm
being honest about it and I'm telling
you my point of view that's all I'm just
telling you what I think same as I would
do for any president or politician see
to me Trump is not a special case Trump
isn't isn't special tea he's just a man
he's a politician he's not the devil
he's not Hitler it's not like everything
he does is wrong he's not plotting to
destroy America okay he's not a fascist
dictator but he's also not God so I'm
not gonna sit here sit and sing his
praises at all at all hours of the day
right he's not he's not all-knowing and
all-wise in all loving he kid he can be
wrong that's the way I look at him
that's the way I look at every human
being on earth that's especially the way
I look at politicians and and so why
would he be any different that's the way
I approach it now that's not to say that
my praise or criticism is always right
maybe it isn't
maybe it's wrong sometimes maybe it's
always wrong maybe I'm a total idiot and
I'm always wrong about Trump that could
be the case but that's not that's not
really the case you made you weren't you
weren't explaining why I'm wrong instead
you went to my motivations and you were
trying to diagnose my motivations and
this is what people often seem to do in
your criticism you claim that for me as
a conservative with a mostly
conservative audience criticizing Trump
occasionally is something I do for
clicks and to make people happy and to
get applause and adulation now that is
so hilariously wrong and off-base and
detached from reality that I can't
believe you believe it but then again
like I said a lot of people say this
kind of thing anytime I do criticize
Trump I get similar emails so this it
seems like a lot of people do think this
and so I will address and I'll try to
break this down free I've explained it
before I'll explain it again and this is
an area where I have some expertise
because I'm in conservative media and so
I think I could speak to it ever since
Trump came on the scene there have been
two approaches to Trump that will get
you clicks and make lots of people like
you know approach
gonna make everybody like you that's
impossible so that's off the table but
in terms of growing an audience building
your own little Amen chorus getting
clicks making money there are two
approaches now obviously if you're on
the left there's one approach and that
is to criticize Trump at all hours at
all in all occasions over everything
give him no credit for anything ever if
you're on the left that's what it is and
very simple that's that's your approach
okay for conservatives though you can
take the Jennifer Rubin approach and
that is to become for all intents and
purposes a full-on Democrat criticize
Trump always in every situation make him
out to be Hitler try to get Democrats
elected start supporting Democrats
openly and basically campaigning for
them and the result of this which is
what some conservatives have done some
so-called conservatives the result is
that is is you're gonna be despised by
people on the right but you might get a
CNN contributor ship you're gonna grow a
nice little audience for yourself you're
gonna be you could be the token Cable
News conservative who criticizes Trump
you can write a book book will probably
do pretty well and it's gonna get you
know you'll get a lot of cable news hits
to sell the book and and all that kind
of you'll get good reviews okay so
that's that's one approach
have I done that do you think CNN is
knocking on my door am I on here spewing
Democrat talking points every day no
obviously not so then there's the other
option and this is the less West risky
option and it's the one that many many
more conservative media figures have
have taken this this has been their
approach and that is to become full
launch Trump groupies stopping very
short of deification and in some cases
not even stopping that short Trump is
never wrong never worthy of criticism
everything he does is brilliant
everything he does is wonderful he is
the best president ever he's a hero and
a pioneer the savior of America America
is great now because of him and it will
be less great when he's gone literally
no compliment is too elevated no action
or statement by Trump is too absurd or
wrong to be defended and if you go this
way which a lot of conservatives have
you'll you'll gain a huge audience you
can write a book about how Trump saved
America and it's guaranteed to be a
best-seller and Trump will also himself
retweet it and you'll get some credit
from that and so you'll sell books that
way you'll get the cable news gigs
you'll speak at CPAC you'll be loved and
adored by the Trump by Trump's White
House and and because they they pay very
close attention to Twitter and to their
you know supporters in the media and so
it's going to get you close to power
that way it's guaranteed to make you
money and it's a very easy approach now
I'm not naming any names but there are
people who are celebrities on the right
now who make a lot of money and have a
huge audience and they do sold-out
speaking events and they sell books when
the only thing they have to offer is a
few tsipras for Trump that's all they
have that's it they've got nothing else
they have no other insights into
anything they have no analysis to offer
on anything they've never said anything
interesting ever ever all they ever do
is just say Trump is wonderful that's
theirs and they go around saying
troubles wonderful and they become
celebrities are they made a lot of money
there there are people like this like I
said not gonna name names I don't think
I need to know I could have done that
you know and and and I could have gone
that route and if I did my podcast will
be 10 times more popular than it is I'd
be on TV way more than I am I could
charge a lot more for speaking gigs and
I'd be making a lot more money and I get
a lot more hits on my articles and
everything else now the approach of
treating Trump not like the devil or
like God not as always praiseworthy or
always blameworthy the approach of
criticizing him sometimes harshly when
you think it's warranted whether you're
right or wrong but when you think it's
warranted and defending him sometimes
passionately when you think that's
warranted that is the very last approach
that someone who is just in it for
clicks and praise would take if there's
a grifter going down that road he is the
dumbest grifter of all time he has taken
them the most difficult path to grifting
there were much easier
things he could have done now I'm not
saying that those of us who take this
approach and I think here in the Daily
wire this is the approach that we take I
go Mike I speak for anyone else I'm
speaking for myself but I also think
that that's that that's you know a
general approach as well I'm not saying
that we're like heroes or something or
martyrs we still do well for ourselves
and we enjoy our jobs and we in fact we
don't really have jobs and so we live
comfortable lives that way so I'm not
saying you should build statues to us
and honor us for our heroism I'm just
saying that if you think that that you
know on a conservative media person who
on occasion issues a harsh criticism of
Trump if you think he's doing that
because he wants clicks you just haven't
you really you honestly have no idea how
this works when I said what I said about
Trump on Friday I knew I was gonna be
killed over it I knew it I knew I was
gonna get all kinds of angry messages
people saying I'm done with you I'm not
following I'm listening anymore there's
gonna be a lot of very angry comments in
the YouTube section about how I'm the
worst host in The Daily wire I'm so
terrible I'm the worst I'm awful I knew
all that stuff would happen I would lose
subscribers I would lose listeners and
and that's you know it'd be much easier
to just not say it and sometimes I think
maybe that's the path I should take
because maybe it's more prudent to just
leave it alone and say nothing but I
can't help myself because I'm a
loudmouth and so I'm just gonna say what
I think again not heroic I mean I'm
still here doing this very easy job but
I I also just think you should
understand how grifting and click
hunting works and if I was interested in
doing that if I ever go that route
you'll know it okay because that that if
I go that route it's gonna be every
single show is gonna become about how
wonderful Trump is or every show will be
how evil he is if that's what this show
turns into then you'll know that I've
been I've sold my soul and now I'm gone
full-on grifting and if I do that just
you know if you see me in public just
slap me in the face please do me a favor
slap some sense into me don't really do
that though please that would be assault
and I would call the police all right
we'll leave it there thanks everybody
for watching thanks for listening it's
been a very hopefully honest show and
we've accomplished that at least stay
safe out there
Godspeed the Matt Walsh show is produced
by Sean Hampton executive producer
Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer austin stevens editor
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 if you prefer facts over feelings
aren't offended by the brutal truth and
you can still laugh at the insanity
filling our national news cycle well
tune in to the Ben Shapiro show we'll
get a whole lot of that and much more
see you there